You really have to see to believe the
things that are happening on Fox News
from all sorts of people who just cannot cope
with the reality that Donald Trump has lost.
And it's actually starting to get hilarious
because of how stupid and cultish it is. Let's
go through a few clips. It'll be a whirlwind tour
of the last day or two on Fox News. This is really
great. Here is Fox News anchor Ainsley Earhardt
on yesterday morning's Fox and Friends episode.
She sort of begrudgingly saying, I guess that
guy, they're sort of calling the president elect,
Joe Biden. The petulance, the stubbornness.
It's just palpable here. Listen to this.
And Steve Doocy son, Peter, who has been on the
campaign trail, and now he's with us with what
they're calling the president elect Biden,
what they are calling President elect Biden.
Isn't that just a delight? They can't they
can't cope. They just can't. It's stunning
the inability to just accept that they've lost.
And then after, of course, earlier this week,
the electors in all 50 states voting, officially
giving Joe Biden the status of president elect,
not media designated anymore, but elector
designated president elect on Wednesday night,
Trump, White House press secretary and senior
adviser to the Trump campaign, Kayleigh McEnany,
appeared on Fox News and just wildly accused
the courts of gimmickry tricks. I don't know
if she meant gimmicky tricks. Gimmickry is a word.
It's unclear if she's actually using it the right
way. Anyway, Kayleigh just can't take anything,
including the fact that courts recognize that
every single one of the 50 claims that the Trump
campaign has made are without merit. Take a look.
Here's what they did, Sean. Here was the
clever little trick. And it happened in Nevada
when the claims were brought beforehand. When
we warned and said, hey, mass mail in voting is
a problem. We brought these courts. We brought
these claims to a court of law. They said, hey,
your claim is not right. Come back after the
election. We bring in after the election to
the same court and they say latches, which is a
legal doctrine, saying your claim is too late,
it can't not be ripe and then be too
late. Those are the kind of gimmickry,
tricks that happens. And we've got to try
to fix this because twenty, twenty two is
on the line. Twenty, twenty four.
She just can't handle it and she will never stop.
She some have jumped ship. Some of the
rats have abandoned the ship. Caylee is
committed to going down with the ship and by
gimmickry I guess she means civil procedure,
due process, constitutional elections, democracy,
the will of the people. That's now called
gimmickry. To Kayleigh McEnany. Then we move on
to a sitting senator, Republican Senator Rand
Paul yesterday morning, also on Fox and Friends
saying without a shred of irony whatsoever,
that the election was absolutely stolen
by Joe Biden from Donald Trump. Do you
think the election was stolen? You tweeted out?
Absolutely. I think there's a great deal of fraud.
Fifty court decisions won't convince him.
Statistical analyzes won't convince him.
He will insist, no matter what, that it was
stolen. And, of course, he golfs with Trump. And I
don't think that the personal relationship with
Trump should be ignored here as least at least
as part of the reason, part of the reason why
Rand Paul is saying this stuff. Here's another
insane one. This is a different Fox News show and
it's Republican Congressman Ken Buck. Ken Buck is
so unable to cope with what's going on that he is
calling for an investigation into Hunter Biden,
possibly even criminal charges against not
only Hunter Biden, but even Joe Biden as well.
Erkan people are fed up with corruption in
Washington, DC. I think they're fed up with
people selling their office for personal
gain. And that's exactly what it appears
President elect Biden did. And if he didn't do
it, we need to have a special counsel to clear
the air. It's the special counsel that should
be answering the questions, just like Special
Counsel Mueller investigated President Trump and
cleared him. If President elect Biden is cleared,
so be it. If he's not cleared, we need to make
sure that we proceed with criminal charges
against Hunter Biden and if necessary,
against Joe Biden when he leaves office.
Buck can't even get his facts straight or maybe
more likely he doesn't care about the facts.
Robert Mueller did not clear Donald Trump. Robert
Mueller actually says in plain language he cannot
clear Trump on obstruction. And if he could clear
Trump on obstruction, he would have said, I can
clear Trump on obstruction and Ken Buck. Going off
into fantasy land now, here's my question for you.
Is this more sad or infuriating
or is it is it both?
And I'm leaning towards it's both like it is
infuriating that these people are in positions
of power. It's infuriating that these people
hold the bully pulpit and set the agenda on media
and all of that. And maybe I'm too you know, one
of the things that we know about the right is they
are completely unarmed, empathetic until something
affects them directly. Maybe I'm too empathetic,
but I find it sad to see adults behaving
in this way just completely unable to cope
with with what is a political loss here. And I
think over the next listen, there's kind of three
time frames that I'm looking at. It's the next few
weeks until January 20. What do we see on right
wing media and from Republicans during that period
of time? Then what do we see during the first few
months of the Joe Biden presidency? And then
what will right wing media sort of settle into
for the duration of Biden's term? And my
expectation is, again, it depends on what
Trump will do and how visible Trump will
be in continuing to foment this insanity.
But I think Republicans and right wing media will
get back to all the normal playbook, thinly veiled
anti-Semitic tropes, as we saw from Tucker Carlson
yesterday, pretending to care about the debt and
deficit. All of the normal stuff that we've
come to see from them. Curious to hear from you